so
uh foreign
so
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
accompanied by the vice president of the
united states
well thank you very much and we're here
to talk about a very important
subject education but also opening our
schools
and we have some of our great teachers
and parents and
a very representative group and we also
have
some extraordinary experts with us
i'd like to maybe start off by asking
our vice president to say a few words
and then if you would betsy and
kellyanne and
we'll go around and talk to some of the
parents and teachers
and thank you all for being here very
much appreciate it
please well thank you mr president i
want to i want to thank
all of the educators and
leaders who are here at a part of a
conversation
president trump made it clear from the
time that we made our way through the
difficult days of 45 days to slow the
spread
the president said we want to we want to
work with states to open up america
again but to open up america we've got
to open up america schools
and at the president's direction we've
literally provided billions of dollars
already
to states to begin to open schools and
secretary devos and i
as you know mr president have traveled
around the country to places like north
carolina and
indiana and louisiana and we are working
literally day in and day out
with governors and state education
leaders to find a way that we can safely
reopen our schools our commitment
is to make sure that that our our states
and our
our schools have the best guidance we'll
talk a little bit about that today
cdc actually issued some new guide posts
mr president not long ago but the first
document they issued was the cdc's
position that it is best for our kids to
be back in school
the cdc's recognize that it's a public
health priority
to have our kids back to school and in
person learning
uh but mr president as you've also made
clear we're gonna make sure our schools
and our states have the resources to be
able to safely
reopen and we're calling on congress to
work with us
to appropriate another 105 billion
dollars we believe
that we can safely reopen our schools we
know that it's best for our kids
we don't want them fall behind
academically but also
we don't want our kids to miss out on
the counseling that they receive
special needs services as well as all
the nutrition
programs that are available just at our
schools
and finally mr president i know that
you've recognized from early on that
getting our kids back to school is first
a priority for them but also it's
important for working families
only about 20 of single parents
are able to telework and so to open up
america again we've got to open up
america's schools to put america back to
work we've got our kids are back in the
classroom and so
mr president i want to thank you for
your leadership it's great to be here
with secretary of education with
kellyanne and all these remarkable
teachers in particular as you know i've
been married to a school teacher for 35
years
she's preparing to go back to the
classroom this fall and i want to thank
all the educators who are here
for all the hard work you've done
through these difficult days and all the
work that you're doing
to get our kids back to school thank you
mr president
mr president thank you so much for your
continued bold leadership
through this crisis and particularly
with respect
to getting kids back to school it's been
a privilege to travel with the vice
president to meet with
educators education leaders and
especially with parents
and students to hear about what their
needs are
as fall quickly approaches and so i'm
i'm just thankful to be here with this
group today to listen and learn from you
about what your needs are as we
anticipate getting back to school and
commissioner corcoran thank you for your
bold leadership in florida
really setting high expectations for all
of the students
and educators there we know that
for students and their families they
can't be held
captive to other people's fears or
agendas
we have got to ensure that families and
parents
have options that are going to work for
their child and for their children's
education
and so uh i look forward to this
conversation too
as to how we can ensure that we do not
have a one-size-fits-all approach but
that we do ensure
every child has a chance to go on
learning full-time this fall
thank you very much mr president mr vice
president secretary devos
we're here mainly to hear from each of
you today before i do that i just wanted
to
point out that there is a fairly recent
kaiser family foundation health tracker
poll that shows
over 65 percent of america's parents are
very concerned that their children will
fall
behind academically and socially if they
don't get back to school
having said that we recognize that many
school districts have already made a
decision
to either go hybrid or full-time virtual
learning for
the first month or two or maybe longer
so our goal today the president's goal
has always been
how do we reopen safely how do we open
soon but how do we reopen safely
we also recognize that a number of
teachers particularly the 10
or so that are over the age of 60 in
most of our schools are concerned
so we have given resources and guidance
that allows each of those districts to
make those decisions
to maybe modify the work schedules of
the teachers and other
administrative staff that may be
affected but overall
we know that the risk is low for kids in
contracting
and being hospitalized and of course the
worst possible outcome
dying from coven 19 but the risk is very
high if they're
locked down indefinitely nearly 100
percent of our 75 million
students k through college left their
places of learning left those structures
between the first and third weeks of
march of this year
and we see that all situations were not
created equally
the digital the lack of digital assets
was very obvious for many of our
students the lack of nutrition
the lack of social and emotional mental
well-being and development
but also we heard from many school
administrators and teachers
they're concerned because roughly one
out of five child abuse cases
are detected in schools so we have to
also think about all that we don't know
and all that is being lost for these
children
by keeping them locked down and
definitely so in the interest of opening
soon and safely
for this entire country mr president
we'd like to start with
elisa from waukesha wisconsin she's a
single mother and a small business owner
and her son luis is entering a public
district school
um in a public district school the ninth
grade i believe freshman year for luis
if you can tell us a couple of things
elisa first of all what were the
relatives advantage or disadvantage of
him being a bilingual student
when you had to go virtual learning and
then we understand that your school
district has not yet announced a
reopening plan and we're
in pretty much mid-august so can you
address both of those for us
correct um yes we as the parents we had
to take a survey
regarding either going back to school or
going virtual
so at the moment we like you had
mentioned we do not have an answer yet
hopefully we do and i'm hoping that we
do go back
because all the details that you just
mentioned are very critical and
important
and i am a hundred percent of what you
guys um
are saying at the moment uh it was
kind of difficult for him because it's
really hard
being bilingual and having
to to learn to different languages
and um but with the help of teachers
and the community he
stood up and did a great job um that was
the advantage that when he needed help
teachers were there um to help him and
you know fulfilled whatever gap you know
was
um not being covered and so he did a
pretty well um after that
but you like going back immediately
right oh yes
a hundred percent a hundred percent
yes you're welcome
dr paul peterson is the director of the
program on education policy and
governance
at harvard university and hoover
institution senior fellow dr peterson
we've heard an awful lot
including from the president the vice
president cdc director and others
about their relative problems that
children could face if they are an
indefinite lockdown
would you please expand on that as a
doctor well we know that if
for every year that you spend in school
uh
in the future you will earn 10 more
in lifetime earnings so if we lock down
schools for a year we assign this
generation of students to a 10
earning loss in the rest of their life i
mean this is profound
that the the costs are vastly greater
than
people uh have appreciated to say
nothing about the
importance of young people being
together with one another the most
important uh
element in social growth is being with
your peers with your own
friends and and neighbors and not being
isolated
in a in a setting where you don't have
social relationships
to say nothing of the medical costs
of being isolated and not you know
i i remember when i was a child i had uh
that the teacher said you know he can't
see he needs glasses
well i've got some new eyes now so i can
see but
yeah you you are told in school what the
problems are
and then you can get those problems
solved all those things are out the door
if you're not in school so sitting in
isolation
with a computer looking at a laptop
is not the same as being out there in
the real world you know at one time
mr president i thought digital learning
was the future but
we have learned through this covet
crisis that we haven't got
digital learning to the point where you
can really
engage young people they've got to be in
that classroom they have to be with
their peers so if you're a
presidential candidate and you're
sitting in a basement and you're looking
at a computer
that's not a good thing sounds like it
would be the same
well i i won't put you on the spot i'm
not going to pick you up
thank you very much a lot of truth to
that
hypothetically speaking yes i don't know
a single parent who thinks their kid
needs more screen time to your point dr
peterson
uh lynn gronseth from arkansas
you've been a special education teacher
i think you're entering your 19th year
but you also
are considered higher risk for
contracting the coronavirus since you
have asthma is that correct
yes tell us how you feel about going
back to school or this my son's a
physician and i will say radiologist
at stanford and so every time there were
rumors and myths
i just called him and said what are you
hearing there and
he never once not once said please don't
go back he went he knows how much i love
my special education
students how much they need those
special resources like your speech
my other colleagues provide the
instruction
was extremely difficult for my students
a lot wouldn't come to the zoo meetings
it's just so different but what i was
going to say is i typed the protocols
from springdale public schools and i'm
very comfortable with them they've gone
beyond the call
of duty i gave that to my allergist
emailed it to my son
and both of them gave me with
precautions the ability to go back and i
want to be there
for my students and help them navigate
through this and make them comfortable
to come back safely
thank you thank you
dr melanie mcgraw piasecki from
charlotte north carolina
a neo nationalist but also a mom of
three who i think has been home with the
kids
helping them navigate the online world
of learning uh could you tell us
both a mom of three who's been home with
them but also through your
medical experience how can we learn to
safely and quickly return to school
sure um my children i would say did not
have a great experience in the spring
particularly my youngest
who was in first grade at the time i
think the online learning for the young
ones
it just doesn't work and my school it's
a private independent school
recognize that and when they go back
next week they're sending the little
ones back every day which i think is
great
the middle and upper school ones will be
back in a hybrid way every other day
and they've incorporated some choice too
so if parents are not comfortable
they're able to do a full online
experience but
we're definitely going back as much as
they'll let us um
in terms of being a pediatrician i just
think the science is so clear
that the risk of death or
hospitalization for children with this
virus is so
so low but we know the risk of missing
school
are catastrophic we probably don't even
know how high they are yet
and they cover so many different areas
so i feel like mr president thank you
for your leadership on trying to get
students back
in school safely associated
and the concept of every other day seems
a little ridiculous right if you're
going to do it you do it if you're not
going to do it the concept of
going back even from a management
standpoint from the school
every other day seems very strange
i think the idea is they're going to
take half the student body on eight days
and half the student body on b days and
so they can
socially distance in the facility doing
it that way and then if you're home
you'll be
watching it on technology okay but you'd
rather see them go back
period right not see that that's right
that's right
great job thank you very much
nielsen alvarez hi it sounds like your
children are back in school uh following
a decision that you and other parents in
seymour tennessee had to make with
respect to whether to keep them at home
and learn virtually or go back to school
you chose to go back to school why and
how is it going so far
well the y is very easy i'm a hispanic
small business owner
so i need my kids in school to run the
business
and i know a lot of families it's a
struggle
if you're working your business and
being teacher at the same time it's just
not easy
but we've made that decision and i
really want to thank
the leadership of governor bill lee who
who
emphasized to the school districts to
offer the options of in-person learning
and virtual so that parents would have
the freedom
to choose which education route
would be best for their child the
parents
in my area and at our school decided to
send our kids back
our kids are excited there is social
distancing there's a lot of protocols in
place their temperatures are taken every
morning
everything is going very smooth but what
what is really good is that my son
and daughter they understand the
seriousness of the virus for those at
risk
so they're keeping an eye out for those
who are at risk so we can look after
them we have a group chat with the
parents
and we're communicating all the time if
there's any symptom
so that we know to you know if
something's happening or not
um whether we send our our kids back to
school that they are not
and because the virtual class is
happening at the same time
our kids will never fall behind
that's great thank you very much well
said
claudia viadares you are a kindergarten
teacher at a public school
and we understand you had a very
successful
in-person summer school experience which
may be very surprising to some people
here that that actually was happening
this summer
can you tell us that from lubbock texas
and also how does that pretend for a
successful in-person fall
yes i'm from lubbock texas and i teach
at ramirez elementary
and we did have a really successful
summer school there were no outbreaks it
was in person
there were precautions with social
distancing six feet apart
and children had to wear masks 10 and
older there was temperatures
taken for the staff and the students
and this year our parents had the choice
whether to do virtual or in person
and so far we have 70 wanting to be in
class
and so we're ready to go and we start
monday
thank you thank you for all of your
leadership with this
thank you thank you mr president
mr president you heard from a couple of
our last speakers
something that you actually have made
happen in signing the cares act there's
about 13 billion dollars worth of
funding
and i was briefed by an hhf hhs official
this morning who said only four percent
has been tapped into they can use that
to help them with the temperature checks
with the testing however they wish to
use it so we would really implore
those states and those local school
districts to take advantage of the money
that you and the vice president
secretary and others have already
secured
in a bipart bipartisan fashion and what
i'd like to do is i'd like to see the
money follow the student
if the school is going to be closed and
we're giving all of this money on the
federal basis to a school
and if a student is going to go to a
different school
really at the choice more of the parent
in all fairness than the student you
know
where you want to go and what school you
want to bring the student to
i think the money should follow the
student
and that's something that we want to do
we're having a hard time with the
democrats they want the money to follow
the union
to be honest it's very simple give it to
the union
but the fact is give it to dues because
the union people are
fantastic people in there but the people
that run the union
it's disgraceful and to do's and they
charge
the teachers and that's what it's all
about so i would like anyway
i would like the money to follow the
student and this way you can make your
own choice
if the school is closed you know why are
we paying if a school is closed why are
we paying the school
i'd rather give it to the student the
parents and you do your own thing
and to me makes a lot of sense
secretary devos well and i would just
add to that
senator tim scott has a bill introduced
in congress that would do just that
would empower parents to make the choice
for their children
to find the right setting and the right
fit for them depending on their
circumstances and with
the president's bold leadership here i i
think we can get it done
congress can do the right thing on
behalf of parents and their kids
so mike we'll let him know we're in
favor of that tim scott is fantastic
and the bill is really good so why don't
we do that okay
we will mr president i assure you
excellent you've always been the school
choice president of the school choice
candidate i know as governor
of indiana vice president pence expanded
charter schools and other educational
freedom
opportunities and i will say that we as
a nation can philosophically and
politically differ on many issues
but i've never ever heard a very
compelling and persuasive memorable
reason why people pose
the kind of school choice that the two
of you are fighting for and school
choice means parent choice
so our last set of questions really go
to the parents and the importance of
parents ability to choose
the right education for their children
particularly within
uh this dual medical and financial
pandemic uh mr president we have with us
today and i want to read it so i get it
all right janie neely of columbia south
carolina she's a former public school
teacher herself
she's a reading specialist her zone
school district plans
to provide full-time virtual instruction
she believes her high schooler
will be fine but her kindergartner has
down syndrome and must receive
in-person instruction janie's husband
chris is here
he serves as the chairman of the
president's committee for people with
intellectual disabilities
thank you very much for being here chris
and god bless both of you and your
children would you like to tell us a
little bit
janie about how you're approaching this
school year absolutely
when school is closed in the spring
abruptly it was
especially difficult for families with
children that have special needs because
for us
it was like falling off an early
intervention cliff
schools not only provide the academics
for students with special needs but it
also provides the much needed therapies
and services
to address developmental delays and the
structure
and routine of school day is so critical
for this population of students
it simply cannot be replicated in a
virtual platform
and especially for a kindergartner with
down syndrome
unfortunately our school district has
adopted a virtual only reopening plan
and it's been extremely disappointing
because as a parent i wish
well i need and i wish that i'd been
given a choice
um because i know for a fact that this
style of learning
um will cause my son to regress and to
fall behind
and we were working so hard for him to
be fully included with his peers
so my hope is that we can all work
together to get in-person
learning um especially open for the
students that are most vulnerable
and to have that choice for parents
because i know my son best and i know
what he needs
really well said uh so it's been a
burden a tremendous burden
and what you've been through has been a
great burden
obviously how do they change that how do
they change it what would you recommend
i think families with children with
special needs were already carrying a
pretty tremendous burden
we are constantly incorporating
different therapies and things of that
nature
what's nice about it being incorporated
in the school is that happens during the
school
day unfortunately in my situation we've
now been forced to change and
to find another school option for our
son we're
fortunate because a lot of families
don't have that option
because smaller schools private schools
parochial schools may not have the staff
and the structure to accept children
with special needs so there's not always
that option we're fortunate in that
situation but now my family's taking on
the burden
of not budgeting and planning for
tuition
so having the dollars follow the student
is very critical for a family like ours
and now i'm also having to plan
all of his therapies on the outside so
we're talking about a kindergartner
that's going to school
from 8 in the morning to 2 30 in the
afternoon and then he has to have
occupational therapy physical therapy
speech therapy all after school that's a
long day
it's a lot of work it is thank you
thank you very much thank you
thank you you know i think the
conversation in america right now the
children with special needs have really
been left out
and so mr president i want to thank this
administration
mr vice president when you and the
secretary came to columbia a few weeks
ago
you addressed that issue that people
with disabilities are being left out
and so what we have here are people that
are on the front lines
in education that are saying we can open
the schools
for everyone i visited two schools this
week
in south carolina that have uh charter
schools
students are in class teachers are there
they're learning they're playing
with each other i mean it's been a great
experience so we could do this in
america we can get america back to
school
and make our education system great
that's great thank you very much
appreciate it
florida's a commissioner of education mr
corcoran you spearheaded
an emergency declaration with governor
desantis basically to
meet the demands of parents for
in-person instruction i'm very struck
when i read these parent surveys in many
districts
parents overwhelmingly are saying yes
when they are asked do you feel it is
safe for your son or daughter to return
to school
and often they're being big footed by a
county health commissioner or school
board
how are you meeting that demand and how
do you know that parents are so in
demand in florida for in-person
instruction
what are you hearing well we did exactly
as i said we did an emergency order that
basically
gave increased flexibility and increased
choice to parents teachers
and the districts um and a certainty in
the funding
but if you're not getting what we were
saying and what got reported it
uh you know the same day you said open
school so they said we colluded
i wish i colluded with you that sounds
like a good idea you like that word
but but we opened up you know we said
you have to open up as an option five
days a week for
for school children and now in florida
we're in august our first schools were
opening up this week
uh and throughout august uh we'll have
all 67 our districts will
open up we've not approved a single plan
to your point and your point
um even in our phase one counties um in
southeast florida
uh we've told them you better open up
for children with unique abilities on
day one
you cannot um do virtual therapies you
can't do virtual and
and we just had a form the other day
with a another parent who had a dance
child and
and that he just thrives when he's
around other kids and when he's at home
he's literally
being diagnosed with depression because
he's not around kids they have to have
that right away
um and so we'll open up and and the
great news is
we'll have probably already we have 13
districts that open up this week
of those 13 districts this is the
amazing thing to your point we are being
sued by the union bosses and they are
disgraceful absolutely disgraceful and
so we have multiple suits going
but the reality is of the districts that
opened up this week
um six of them have almost a hundred
percent teacher participation you know
what teachers want teachers want to be
back in the classroom
with their kids even if they have an
underlying condition they want to be
back
and that's what we're seeing in florida
and when we get to august 31st all the
districts open up
we're going to have probably 70 to 80
percent of students in face-to-face
options
and will have more than that percentage
in teachers in the classroom with their
students
and there's just no substitute for it
you know you hear it
we have the largest virtual school in
the country it is a a
second-tier education the best education
is when you got a great teacher a great
mentor someone who's got great wisdom
all the peers the children and their
peers together getting a great education
and an education
um we say in is everything education is
freedom education is the uplifting
of the human soul to the glorious light
of truth and to deny a child
that kind of education you're robbing
them of a lifetime not just of earnings
a lifetime of who they are as human
beings
and i stole that from frederick douglass
but that
but that is that is really what
education goes to and and that's what
i loved what the royal academy said when
they said you're you're scaring a
generation of children for
for um their futures that's what we're
doing when you don't have that option
but hey
if you're a parent i have six children
two in elementary school one in middle
two in high school one in college all
public school all of them are going back
to school
but but i completely respect and wanted
to honor
the decision of a parent who says well
what about i don't feel safe
i think the evidence is overwhelming
we've all seen it but but if they
you have that right if you want to do
distance learning we're going to do the
best possible way
but to the other 70 80 percent of us we
have the right to to go back
and have our kids get that world-class
education it is interesting because one
thing we've learned during this horror
show of uh
the china plague is that virtual
is not as good as being there virtual is
just not the same thing and
for a long time we've been hearing how
great it would be how great it would be
well we've had the ultimate sample right
namely the whole country practically and
it's not as good
we've also learned that telehealth is
very good telehealth is up three
thousand
five hundred percent it's can you
imagine that three thousand
five hundred where people can stay in
there in their homes
their apartments wherever they are and
they can not have to go to hospitals and
doctors and everything else that's been
an incredible success
you know who would have thought that's
become tremendous and
really has been good but the virtual
learning is not like being in a
classroom
and we've learned that i think very
strongly in almost all cases
people thought for a long time that
would be the answer but it's uh that's
not the answer
the answer is an old-fashioned one isn't
it huh thank you great job you're doing
florida thank you very much
mr president our final guest is a mom in
fairfax county lindsay ammon
she's one of the parents who said yes to
the question do you feel
safe returning your children to school
and her older daughter
will have in fairfax county just on four
half days of virtual instruction at her
grade level
and one day off so lindsay has decided
to exercise her parent choice and do pod
homeschooling
can you tell us about that please yes
absolutely
um that's all correct um everything that
everyone has already mentioned
we also had a very poor experience with
virtual learning
um the kindergarten age i think is very
difficult
as everyone has already spoken about but
um
she also it's important to note was an
absolute lover
of learning in general she is very brave
very eager to learn
and we really watch that all fade
we watched her education deteriorate and
we also really saw her mental health
suffer
over the course of the spring so we were
you know very eager to get her back
into in-person learning and we really
felt very confident
and comfortable with the precautions
that were put in place
by our district originally we were
offered
two days in person three days
virtual and then that's actually since
changed over the last
few weeks and we are now 100 virtual
fortunate for us we had already kind of
gone a different route and
set up a homeschool um situation
for her with a small group of parents
in our community and you know we're very
grateful for that
that that was certainly not you know an
easy choice to make
um it was an unexpected cost and
something we hadn't planned for but we
felt like it was really really
important for her to be in a classroom
setting
thank you very much thank you very
uniform
very interesting and i think most people
do feel this way
wouldn't you say so i think most people
feel this way
we have a man with us who's a great
expert from stanford he's working with
us he's consulting with us
and he's going to be at our press
conference in a little while at
5 30 but maybe uh scott atlas dr scott
atlas could say just a couple of words
and
we're going to be covering it in more
detail in a little while and
you folks are uh if you're interested in
watching we'd love to have you
scott please okay thank you mr president
it's a great honor to be
uh asked to help out in any way i can
and the event i thought was terrific
i want to thank everyone for
participating and sort of to reiterate
the bottom line on this as the president
and vice president
and secretary devos have said which is
we know
that the risk of the disease is
extremely low for children even less
than that of seasonal flu
we know that the harms of locking out
the children from school
are enormous and we also know as we all
would agree
that educating america's children is
right at the top of the list for our
nation's priorities so i uh
thank the president and everyone here
for uh acknowledging these
truths and to get kids back to school
safely
thank you thank you scott it's very good
so we'll have
uh more from scott in a little while
we're going to meet together and
we've been working with him very closely
all of the task force all of the
white house and we've made a lot of
progress we've made tremendous progress
you see countries other countries are
now blowing up in terms of
the uh the disease you call it what you
want so many different names for the
disease whether it's
china virus and some i won't get into
because i just kept myself in trouble
every time i do but i'm
i'm angry about it and so is everybody
else in this country angry about it
so we will have a press conference in a
little while you'll be seeing
uh the doctor you'll be seeing a few of
the people and
i'll be making a statement and i think
that'll start at about 5 30.
i want to thank everybody very much for
coming
in and being with you we're on your side
100 we're on your side we'd like to also
see football get going
uh we want to see college football and i
don't know what they're doing with high
school football but i guess it's the
same
kind of a thought process so we want to
see that happen and
i think some of it will happen uh to a
large extent it's going to happen they
want to do it i'll tell you who wants to
do it or the players or the coaches they
want to do it
i spoke with trevor lawrence the great
quarterback
and uh he's uh very smart he understood
it very well he said hey i'm a lot safer
in the field than i am being out there
and uh he he got it he got it very
quickly
uh coach oh i spoke with him he's uh
he's some coach that one he's a great
coach and he
he feels his players just want to be out
there so
we've spoken to a lot of different
people and they want to get out
and our country is opening up we're
opening up very strongly if you look at
retail sales numbers car sale numbers
used card numbers
and employment numbers we have
we're hiring over the last three months
the most
people ever hired in the history of our
country so you had a lower base but
nevertheless we hired a tremendous
amount by far the biggest
number of people ever hired during a
three-month period so for the quarter
so i just want to thank everybody we'll
see you folks in a little while and
thank you very much it
[Applause]
mr president mr president what do you
say to the families that are not
that don't feel safe with their kids
going back to school
thank you very much
[Music]
a man
all right let's get moving pack it up
you